[Music]
fans are paying their final respects to
Aretha Franklin bands of the late Queen
of Soul are gathering together at the
Charles H Wright Museum of African
American history in Detroit Michigan on
Tuesday and Wednesday for public viewing
of her gold-plated casket Franklin
dressed in red from head to toe will lie
in repose for a couple of days in a
queen of soul inscribed casket
surrounded by roses as her gospel
recordings play in the background
according to an eyewitness massive
bouquets of pink flowers from friends
and family surround her including a red
rose bouquet shaped like a heart from
her grandchildren are--this friends and
family will be able to attend a private
funeral on Friday at Detroit's greater
grace temple where former President Bill
Clinton is among those expected to speak
and stars like Stevie Wonder Faith Hill
Jennifer Hudson Fantasia and Jennifer
Holliday will perform Franklin died on
August 16th from pancreatic cancer she
was 76 years old
[Music]
you